[Musique]
les nominés dans la catégorie jeunes
sportifs sont toujours accès malgré ce
qu'avait fait de la moto sur quatre ans
je suis actuellement sur la rive est
alors celui ci la salle saint saulvienne
non pas fou c'était de longues minutes
pour montrer qu'ils étaient conscients
on confirme les chaque jour du coup on
s'est bien préparé pour
après montée au championnat fois c'est
où j'en suis maintenant à habiter un
point commun c'est une perte du coup
j'ai vu la championne en martinique
après on a commencé sur les 150 où il y
a
le championnat de guadeloupe et après
l'état
la mission qui nous est ici
[Musique]
et cette difficulté c'était des
difficultés financières du coup grâce à
la ct mais à tous les partenaires dont
je suis monté cet obstacle et me voilà
bien l'installer au championnat france
[Musique]
perspectives d'avenir sont déjà reçu mon
bac pro qui est qui sied aux trois ans
et après pourquoi pas être
être champion de france
cette santé je m'appelle ludwig vaillant
j'ai 22 ans et je pratique de
l'athlétisme notamment du 400 métiers du
400 métro et
[Musique]
l'activité consiste à faire le tour de
piste avec les obstacles pour le 400
mètres et il sent les obstacles
graphiques le 400 m le sport c'est un
bon moyen pour s'épanouir ils pourront
pratiquer une activité physique donc
bénéfique pour la santé d'épanouissement
personnel
[Musique]
c'était jeunes talentueux c'est est
actuellement romane de matinée il a il a
l'espoir de progresser de s'améliorer de
faire partie des meilleurs français au
niveau de l'élite et notamment sur 400 m
400 m lors termes d'épanouissement
personnel ce que l'athlétisme m'a
rapporté notamment ce sont les voyages
ainsi que différentes rencontres j'ai
commencé l'athlétisme à l'âge de 10 ans
au sein de l'athletic de salé 1
donc l acs à regard salée j'ai commencé
par le demi fond c'est à dire le 1000
mètres ensuite je suis monté
progressivement sur le 400 m le 400 m
haies et maintenant le 200 m
[Musique]
je m'appelle ramassamy cédric mon
activité c'est le cycliste la sécu c'est
le mental déjà premièrement et après les
gens me suivent
si on n'a pas le mental bien les jambes
ne peut pas y aller
et il ya quand même des coups ce qu'ils
sont vraiment difficiles ou si on n'a
pas le mental pour s'accrocher un bain
on perd on baisse les bras et on ne
réussit pas
ça fait déjà plus de 13 ans je pratique
du vélo
le cycliste j'ai commencé dans les
petites catégories
j'ai appris à évoluer
comme je vais dire quand j'ai débuté je
faisais pas dans les dix premiers au fur
et à mesure je me suis entraîné j'ai
fait des performances
j'ai commencé à voir des photos d'hommes
en catégorie supérieure
et après chez les seniors jusqu'à avoir
le titre de champion de france et je lui
trois fois consécutives et après j'ai
que j'ai eu quand même notre discipline
qu'est le vélo sur piste
j'ai pratiqué pas mal de vélo sur piste
en métropole dont j'étais aussi champion
de france du kilomètre sur piste
[Musique]